So you see how the deliberately abusive stuff. Somebody somebody
said somebody said teacher student power differential that is
like that is the absolute >> that's like your cop >> that
is [laughter]
>> No it's the power difference like the fact that they're
like very innocent and very corruptible and it's like NO THAT'S
THE THING THAT'S THE ACTUAL THAT'S THE CHILDLIKE ESSENCE THAT'S
THE THING YOU'RE ATTRACTED TO INNOCENT CHILDLIKE essence stop
so [music]
this is the food shops PDF file manifesto. Let's let's take a
look. The dissension daybook. I don't know why it's called this.
Introduction.
I'm food shops and I uploaded my first YouTube video on May 24th,
2023 titled I will show you the true horror of Hardtock Bronze
Valerant. If you check the progression of my videos leading up
to the most recent, none of them are reminiscent of the very
first YouTube video regarding Hardstuck Bronze Valerant.
mainly because I did a lot of experimentation around content
in my early days, especially on Tik Tok, YouTube, and kick. I
still keep a lot of that content up, mainly because I want to
be able to own that content and say I improved over time, even
the shameful, embarrassing, or weird bits. However, calling some
of my early content weird would be a vast understatement, as
I explored some extremely controversial and taboo topics, especially
targeting and involving and I was personally invested in the
topic, but I also made it a core part of my content. Due to the
controversial nature of the topic, it captured people's attention.
Once I have captured people's attention, then I would actually
go into the real discussions and good faith discourse to get
people onto my side.
That's very weird. That's very odd that you're saying it's a
you're personally invested in the topic, but I also made it a
core part of my content. Okay. Interesting. Interesting.
Since then, I've reluctantly set to private all related and loyon
content and debates due to the feedback I received.
The main point that was brought up was the trouble/controversy
is not worth it as a content creator, even though I defended
my main content subject at the time. The reason this was a hard
decision for me was because I felt personally attached to the
subject matter, which is explained in the next section.
Okay, so this is going to be going into the PCD stuff. Now, months
later, after not talking about my old content so much in public,
I've revealed not only my own beliefs, but very sensitive personal
details on a public liveream. So, she went live and basically
tried to talk about how she her therapist prescribed her off
to as a way to deal with her OCD, which didn't happen. Pretty
much any therapist will tell you that didn't possibly happen.
That never would have that couldn't have possibly happened. She's
just lying, right? She read something that talked about exposure
therapy and she thought, "Oh, I'll I'll do it this way." without
ever consulting a professional. Okay.
With all the clips, tweets, and coverage on me, the time has
come for me to use this write up to present everything on the
table, my views, where I'm coming from. So, everything is gathered
in one
My OCD. I have OCD. I got the diagnosis from a second therapist,
the second therapist I ever had. There is a popular perception
that OCD is about cleanliness and orderliness. However, it is
an anxiety disorder that is more along the lines of of cycles
of rituals and compulsions which can manifest in a near numerous
in a near numerous near infinite maybe is what they meant number
of forms
near numerous number of forms.
It manifested in multiple forms but I can remember it being significant
only in three primary forms. One of these forms are strange attachment
fixation issues where I get incredibly fixated on specific people
in a limrant. Limrance referred off-handedly
lirance referred off-handedly in the OCD context specifically
refers to an OCD manifestation where the fixation is primarily
focused around another person romantic or attraction based way.
I get immensely obsessed with them, feel bad when they are not
there and think about them basically all day and all night. The
very last liberant cycle is actually what got me to help get
help in the first place and what got me on my on meds to get
therapy and to fix my issues the best I could.
Uhhuh.
Okay. This is rough. Well, this is rough given their content,
right? And what you would assume is their fixation currently.
And
Another is what I call confession compulsion where I would always
try to confess things that I felt were bad to people I perceived
as good, ranging anywhere from bad thoughts to bad feelings to
bad actions I did with time and effort. I have also kind of kept
this kind of spiraling under control. However, I cannot deny
that it wouldn't be surprising if this contributed in at least
some small part to my personality, my behaviors and actions.
For the sake of this booklet, I have only described confession
compulsion and liance for the sake of transparency. Both confession,
compulsion, and lirance will not be mentioned as a part of my
argument for the rest of the manifesto. However, the third manifestation
mentioned is especially insidious called PCD or OCD.
Basically, it is a this constant fear and worrying that you are
a however this does not mean you're an actual, but rather you
have the OCD cycle applied to the entire to the anxiety that
you might be one.
During my primary PCD spiraling days, I found out what had to
go through since I convinced myself that I was one,
which was specifically a sense of overwhelming guilt and self-hatred
that they are monsters. I developed my during my feverous research
I developed during my feverous research an empathy for people
who suffer through actual
Since then, I felt an urge to defend non-offending from the everyday
social stigma of guilt as well as rehabilitating offending back
into society without committing another crime. However, I want
to make it clear that this is not because I want to justify
actions for myself or other people, but rather to promote discussion
and mental health coverage of the idea and for a group of people
who suffered through immense day-to-day guilt. This ultimately
was one of the main contributing factors to my early content
creation. Well, that's really funny given the tweet from earlier
today. Hold on, let me pull it up. Where she basically
combines like child abuse, right? So, this is totally at odds
with the things she's saying now because she is essentially earlier
today combining child abuse with everything else. Hold on. Which
is this the one
about the police? This is like totally at odds with the things
she's saying in this manifesto, right? No FBI raid, no police
raid, no charges, no arrest to this day. Amazing. The progressive
left shows their true colors of being an anti-Semitic transphobic
hate mob. you're a she is explicitly laying out in this manifesto
her understanding of the difference between a child abusing offending
and a non-offending.
She knows that you could be a without touching a kid. She knows
that.
But she's trying to basically muddy those two things together
to try to get out of trouble here. Not going to work. All right.
So she knows that you could be a without doing any crimes and
that that would still be an accurate label and that she has herself
said that she feels like she falls under that label. Right.
Okay.
So uh we go to the next section
Uh at my core
at my core due to the recent drama of writing this some people
believe I am a to some people I am not. Some people believe it
doesn't matter if it matters to you the reader. I am not a
I think
in my mind when she does this right it's after lying about her
treatment it's after lying about her PCD
I think she realizes how she can't go forward with this label
and so that's what this manifesto is. So when she says she's
not a I look at the previous lying statements as well as the
lies about these lies and I I go, "Yeah, I think you have some
genuine underlying attraction that I'm very suspicious of." Okay.
It went so far as basically presenting like emails from a therapist
that she talked to about OCD in some way and saying that it was
about her POCD, like lying about her treatment stuff as well.
Okay,
so we continue. I think whether or not someone is a matters when
it comes to keeping people safe in the online space and in real
life. I think it matters when it comes to people's genuine thoughts
and feelings around this issue. However, I think that when it
comes to discussions, arguing points, and expressing real data,
the part should not matter whatsoever. True discover that they
are attracted to children early on around puberty or so, and
when they begin to experience what the is happening. Oh, I see.
Sorry, I had something going on in my background. Uh, true. Yeah.
Okay. Begin to experience their first attraction. I believe that
when it comes to true pedophiles like regular men and women with
regular attractions, most of their attractions are going to be
centered romantically, spending time around who they like. Okay.
Uh rather than sexually from the accounts from real pedophiles
from a Q&A that I have done with Virtuous Pedophiles, an
organization that I've previously reached out to for inquiry.
So, is she about to argue that she doesn't want a romantic relationship
with kids, so she's not a That's uh that's pretty weird, but
okay. I also believe that open and honest conversation, debates,
and discussions about this subject is immensely important when
it comes to helping both the innocent and rehabilitating the
guilty in addition to victims of abuse crimes. However, I do
know that optics matter. Therefore, due to the things that I
have said and the ways that I have said them on stream, people
have incorrectly labeled or insinuated to me as somebody to which
I am not.
As I grow larger, I have also I have also have to recognize that
I have to be more cognizant of how I present to others and people
around me than I have been in my past. So twice she basically
said she didn't care if Mr. Putin was calling her a pedile. Okay.
This like two months ago and again like a month ago or two months
ago she was saying that she's like there's nothing that can change
her being into law really significantly. Okay. Okay. In my opinion,
the topic and pedophile the top this topic and not the attraction
needs to be destigmatized so that non-offending are able to come
forward and offer themselves up for research purposes because
a lot of the data come from person-only statistics which are
heavily skewed as well as my belief that shaming and stigma does
not help with improving lives in general. Out of all the topics
has been one of the most well-poisoned topics ever. I truly believe
that in order to talk about it, good and honest discourse has
to be held.
Okay.
again, good and honest discourse, but then she's constantly referring
to herself as a and how she likes little kids and how she wants
little kids and how she's attracted to little kids. It's like
where's the good and honest discourse happening there? Either
that's good and honest and you believe in good and honest discourse
or you're lying for viewership and to create like I don't know
drum up I guess like a furer over you. Okay, we're down to the
next section. well poisoned on the broad controversial subjects
of Twitchbowl
has to be at the very bottom if not near the very bottom
where whatever oh sorry whenever it is brought up it is always
brought up in the context of somebody's unfortunate accident
or slip up of words I do not mind it being me'd on or brought
up in a context of nervous laughter but there should be a time
and place of serious discourse around it regardless of the optics
of the matter for example the following questions could be academically
relevant do the pros outweigh the cons when it comes to yes but
sorry all of This stuff goes away the second you start joking
about wanting to [__] kids. Like you you sort of
out yourself as somebody who can have this conversation when
you start making what you say are now jokes, which weren't jokes
back then, right? If you're going to if you're going to joke
around it, if you're going to make it a joke, you are no longer
capable of engaging in the serious conversation around it, right?
That's to me if you want to say it's serious and you it shouldn't
be me'd, then you can't do that. And
in the best case scenario, this person has done that, right?
Read reception part. Virtuous
God.
Oh well, we didn't necessarily want this in our history, but
there it is.
Reception. The group's efforts have been discussed with human
by human experts such as Jesse Bearing, local executive director
of exploited child division of NickMeck.
Joe Shian has argued the group may be a cover for that wish to
share strategies for grooming children, stating that while on
the cover you think while on the cover you think there may be
legitimate reasons and purposes, not everybody who joins those
groups has an altruistic motive. In 2017, Alexander McBride of
Vice News wrote, "Many of these claims of non of non-offending
cannot be verified. Perhaps some are using uh virtuous as a cover-up.
Perhaps some who are even more daring saw my photo as a way to
prove they had nothing to hide. I cannot guarantee that this
is not the case, and I understand why many would be suspicious."
Is Alexander McBride the person who founded it? That would be
unfortunate. It's not.
Oh, of Vice News. Sure, sure, sure, sure, sure.
Okay. Wow. Jesus. Okay. All right. We're
She interviewed a bunch of VIP people. Oh, virtuous people. Okay.
Okay. All
Okay. We're continuing. For example, the following questions
may be active. We read this. Let's get Let's get this out of
the way. Yes, I consume. Yes, I recognize it is drawing child.
Yes. Okay. Just immediately.
Okay.
There. There we go. Now, the funny thing is is we can all tell
that that is the bad moment of this, right? That's the bad that's
the obvious bad moment right there. Obviously, that's everybody's
like, "Oh, well, we're done. We're done here." Right?
It is funny because I do believe the the edited version, which
I have here as well. Okay. In the edited version, I do believe
they changed this. This is one of the things they actually edit.
Uh, get this out of the way. Yes, I consume. I also recognize
that it is worrying to the degree that it resembles children
in art. Yeah. So, they knew they could tell somebody must have
told them. I wouldn't be surprised if it was short fat otaku
who told them this. Okay. Hey, maybe maybe don't say that. That
sounds really bad. That sounds really really bad. Maybe don't
say that at all. So, when she edited it and tried to change it
to make it more, you know, so people would be more receptive
of it, she edited that line out. But her true feelings were,
"Yes, it is drawn child and that doesn't bother me." That's another
very concerning thing to say, especially when
right? Especially when you're like laying out your feelings and
trying to say this is how I truly feel about this. It's very
concerning.
Okay. Very, very, very concerning.
All right.
What did we Did I get a link here? The entire thing is just this.
What is this? Hold on.
We got to definitely write a song about how we do not didd kids.
Do not dd kids. It's no good diddling kids. >> There is
no quicker way for people to think that you are diddling kids
than by writing a song about it. You got TO WRITE A SONG, oh
I wouldn't do it with anybody younger than my daughter. No little
kids got to be big, older than my wife, older than my daughter.
Something like that.
>> You know, this really does hit. We got to do a manifesto
about how we don't ddle kids. Okay. We do not We don't Only mid20s.
Only mid20s. Okay. Only mid20s. We don't did kids. It is actually
exactly this. Wow. Rare rare link coming through with like the
actual perfect meme. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
So, let's start it from the top. Food shop says, "Let's get this
out of the way. Yes, I consume."
Food shop says food shop says yes I recognize it is drawn port
child food shopop says I'm doing it on both sides I'm doing it
on both sides okay I should cut it off halfway in the middle
and say food jobs goes on to say okay we don't want to get clipped
reading this bro
oh where was I recognize it is immensely optically damaging for
me especially being a transgender person in the space to admit
this and especially since I believe in content creator responsibility
to some degree
Oh, wait. Immensely optically damaging.
It's like every single So, she recognizes that she is hurting
herself. She's possibly like putting trans people under a lens.
And she felt like she could go out and virtue signal that other
people are transphobic for calling her a dude.
Like, she recognizes the exact problem with her doing this, right?
And she feels like it's appropriate now to go out and go, "This
person's transphobic. This person is transphobic.
Why are they admitting this? Uh, this is something from 2023.
This is why when food shop started being like Destiny's, you
know, stalwart defender. I was like, "Oh, that works out well
for everybody." Actually, that that there's literally nobody
who's upset about that.
Uh, yeah, please, by all means, like, lean into this person.
I warned Dan. I warned I warned everybody about this. Like, there
was nobody who was unaware of this when they started like leaning
into the food shops content going on our stream. Every single
person was aware of all of this.
every one of them. I do this because so food shops continues.
I do this because I believe in telling the truth here now that
it is out and to face reality headon before moving on with the
discourse with the facts and concessions on the table. With that
accounted for, the data is lacking that there's a clear leadup
from consuming to harming a child in the real world on a large
scale. Guys, there's no conclusive data that says I would kids
for after consuming. Okay.
At scale, it's only anecdotes. As in, you can probably find an
anecdote of a child who consumes, but no good statistics behind
a correlation between child yet. I'm open to having my mind changed.
Wow.
I also do not see any real data just yet of how many people who
consume are actually true as defined in the previous section.
While it may seem preemptively obvious, so she's not even saying
that she doesn't have attraction to kids. She's saying she doesn't
have a like primary attraction to young kids or a romantic attraction
to young kids. The way that they defined it before was that as
along with your primary attraction as that was developing that
would be your primary romantic attraction as well. You'd be romantic.
She's like, "Well, I'm not romantically attracted to kids." I
believe this is part of the small people thing. Okay. Yeah. I
don't I just don't know me relating to this attraction versus
romantic attraction.
Oh, what is this? >> I am not gay.
I have relationships with women
and with men >> and I got news for you. That means you're
gay. >> Boo jobs be like I just I just like drawing images
of little kids and it's like I got news for you, man.
That's some kind of Listen, you're off to little kids getting
I don't know what to tell you, man. I don't know what to tell
you, dog. I don't know what to tell you, dog. This rough, man.
Okay. All right.
So I do al so I'll start this paragraph again. I also do not
see any real data just yet of how many people who consume are
actually true as defined in the previous section. While it may
seem preemptively obvious that since there is a good indicator
out there that people who consume real child are true, this is
not necessarily a true case for now that I've admitted to consuming
I can only say from my own experience that I don't think I experience
any closer to wanting I experience any closer to wanting to harm
anybody in the real world at all. Okay, so she's saying like
now now I consume I don't I don't want to kids. saying apparently
I feel like that's one of those rough moments where it's like
yeah but you you know all the things that go along with this
like there's there's literally nothing but disincentive for you
to tell the truth right there's nothing but disincentives for
you to tell the truth and you have expressly like talked about
your attraction to young people to kids it to multiple people
multiple times in a way that does not exclude kids in the real
world food shops is I believe in the best case like a virtuous
okay that wouldn't kid but is absolutely absolutely attracted
to them.
Okay, obviously this is just an anecdote and thus is not academically
rigorous. The truth is destigmatizing the subject would allow
for more research on it to be funded.
Wow.
I do believe you hurt the concept of this entirely like food
shops actually the concept of this right.
So on November 15th,
I
my dog.
Hold on. >> On September 16. >> 16, not 15. [__]
>> My dog
in a dream.
Only in a dream.
Dude, this song is in my head all the time. The absence of charity
intro. On November 15th, I got into a call with the content creator
Resir revealing information about myself and others. On the subsequent
day, November 16th, a hit piece was released on me calling me
a liar and a villain. Ultimately, this is what inspired me to
make this write up in the first place. The purpose of the timeline
is to as much as I could, everything I could gather what is relevant.
as much as I could, everything I could ga everything I could
gather that is relevant to present to you, the reader, the full
context. After that, your own judgments may be made. There's
the talk that ended it and the hit piece. These are from Are
these both resi videos? They're both not going to be here. They're
both long gone. Very, very long gone. I just wonder if you could
see I assume they're both resi videos. Okay. Noticeable noticeable
clips. The chain.
I think at some point in the talk I suspected something was wrong.
And that's why before I was freaking out a little bit and was
too afraid to leave the call out of being called a coward and
my brain wasn't working properly. Either way, yes, I admit that
I am attracted to I don't like lying and I don't like dancing
around the truth. As a content creator, I promised myself a long
time ago that I wanted to put all the facts on the table before
proceeding with any talk. So that is why I overshared
the chain.
No way. This is still here, right? This is gone. This is gone.
I wonder if I've got archived clips
I probably do have archive clips somewhere. I'll I'll find them
in just a second.
I'm sure we can find them. I also answered that I don't think
I think that there are there can be a solid hypothesis made for
a correlation between
but there is no solid studies or number of studies that came
out just yet in full support of it. Furthermore, the question
didn't semantically get processed in my mind as in the art style
being a deviency attraction. But I I do not get the general idea
or sorry but I do get the general idea. I also said before I
was cut off by Resir that I also do not think every time somebody
consumes that they are thus my answer of no. Okay. He then digs
into my history and frequency of searching for which I cannot
give an answer to off the top of my head. I knew then that if
I hesitated too much it would look optically terrible. However,
I gave if I gave any kind of percentage it would look terrible
anyway. I feel as though at this point if I gave any answer I
would be putting the nail putting in the nail in the coffin.
I feel as though Resir should have known and recognized this
as my friend and self-proclaimed dad figure. Okay. Yes, it is.
Yes, I know how bad it looks to the average person. Yes, you
can condemn it. But I'll still be as honest as possible to the
audience even when they put my spot by res was even when I was
put on the spot by Resir. It is what it is. The chain the What
is this? What are these even referencing? Hold on. Let me go
look at the whole set of like information I have here. One second.
Resir stuff. Reserv stuff. Where's the res of your stuff?
>> You know what I mean?
>> you're not attracted to children, right?
>> Chat. Chat. She is not [__]
>> I'm trying to think. >> Yeah, you're not a Right.
I'm trying to
I really got to go back through my mind and and figure out,
am I a
I really need to think. There's a head scratcher right here.
Wait, what question is chat talking about? Are you attracted
to children? >> No. What the >> Okay, cool. Great.
>> Now, I think Hold on. I think there's an excuse that
comes out here that she said, "Oh, you lagged out of the Discord
or something, right?" Am I crazy? I've seen some response to
this.
I think she started saying after that like, "Oh, actually the
Discord was cutting out." Holy [__] I thought that
wasn't the >> Oh my god. That's literally the That was
what I just said. Oh my god. >> I thought that wasn't I
thought the question was like the >> He asked her like
eight times, by the way. He asked her like like literally four
or five times in a row. >> I thought you guys were talking
about like the um private video thing. No, no, it that's all
I asked. >> are you attracted to
>> Yeah, I think I think I literally admitted to this before
on stream. >> Do you think
>> um No. >> Okay. Why do you not think it's better?
>> Because um
because I think I said this before, but like not literally every
single time that you jack off to like a certain is going to be
that. But like >> Do you seek out regularly to master it?
>> How often do you seek it out? Oh, that's actually I
think she goes back on this one and says yes after this >> probably
sometimes. Sometimes not.
>> We're into this part of the debate. I do think she's
basically said no. I do it like a lot now.
Yikes. Okay. It's funny that all the answers tend to flip all
over the place all the time.
But this is what she's talking about. So I answered that I don't
think. So we're into this part. All right. We're into this part
of the manifesto. this the relevant content >> I guess
I don't know like I don't know like I >> I realize like
I've got like a third it's like it's like I have like moms
>> um then like hardcore
and um
[laughter] costumes
for like that's usually I go through >> Thank you. Thank
you Resi. Thank you for just throwing that in. Resi's like just
just in case you feel you know out on your own here. I'm also
going to throw this out. By the way, I'm not even I'm not casting
you know judgment on anything there. I don't care to cast judgment.
I'm just saying it's very funny that he's like explicitly laying
that out. >> I just like it's like okay last time I did
moms. Okay, we're gonna go to free use. Let's go. Um that's like
the next one, right? >> Like I I would say probably out
of my >> So you just like do so you do you seek >> I'll
say I I'll say I'll say probably out of my top five or top six
or whatever the [__] right? For kinks or fetishes
or whatever >> is like do you mean like the aesthetic or
just like the the kids?
>> Um probably it's definitely the power difference. It
is more of the power difference more than anything else.
So that's
um what wait huh? You know resi totally switch up. He's like
wait what? Wait no that's the thing. Wait what?
Wait huh huh. If you're just attracted to the body type it's
like okay there are adults who are like that and you could maybe
somehow get away with it. It's like no it's the power difference.
Like the fact that they're like very innocent and very corruptible
AND IT'S LIKE NO THAT'S THE THING. THAT'S THE ACTUAL THAT'S THE
CHILDLIKE ESSENCE. THAT'S THE THING YOU'RE ATTRACTED TO. IT'S
A CHILDLIKE ESSENCE. STOP. STOP. STOP. >> LIKE, it's probably
only the power
>> It's kind of [__] >> but it's not
like it's not the lack of secondary um characteristics. I'll
say >> Oh, that's really weird. So, she says it's actually
the power difference. It's not the secondary characteristics.
And later on, when she's talking to the other person in private,
oh, hold on. Let me pull these tweets. Let me pull these tweets.
So, when she's talking to the 17-year-old in private that she
didn't know was 17, but it is a 17-year-old. when she talked
to this person in private. We've got these screenshots she gives
and she explicitly
what here.
Uh I feel gross an actual kid but I'm into super petite like
small and small.
So this is less than a year is like 9 months later where she
is explicitly saying I'm actually super into the petite stuff
the little people. So she is into the secondary characteristics.
So realistically her answer here is I'm into both the power dynamic
and the sexual secondary characteristics,
right? It's rough. It's it's rough. It's rough. >> The
power difference. >> Wait, I can't hear you. >> Oh,
sorry. Um I'm sorry. I'm just like thinking about it cuz you're
saying like the power difference. Oh, it's cuz I have my mic.
Sorry. The power
>> Not Not the secondary characteristics or >> No,
no. Lack thereof. Lack thereof. Yeah. Lack thereof. Yeah. >> Because
usually usually Okay. Usually when we're talking about like troops,
>> Okay. Usually when we're talking about true, they are
attracted to the lack of secondary um characteristics, right?
This person's like incapable of object permanence or argument
permanence, lie permanence. They tell some lie or they say something
on a stream and they can't remember the things they've said before
and so they end up making themselves look like an absolute.
So her argument here is I'm actually not attracted to like the
secondary characters. the look of a child, the young look. I'm
not into that. And later on, she's explicitly talking about how
elated she is about this IRL that she's found. Okay, I can't
believe this cute IRL Japanese girl is in the space who's actually
into me. That's why I think I'm being catfished. She literally
talks about that se that set of secondary characteristics being
the thing she's attracted to. She is referred to herself as being
an unreliable narrator with regards to herself. Well, that seems
in that seems obvious. That seems obvious that she's an unreliable
nar narrator with regards to herself. That's maybe the one thing
everybody can agree on here. Okay. >> Uh so you're okay.
>> But like I would say I would say like that stuff is
not within my top three. I was like L.
>> Okay. This is definitely Quella right here, right? When
you look at it, it's more like you're putting yourself in the
place of the child. Is that it? Trying to get food shops to admit
to auto. Not cool. Not cool.
Not cool. I do believe
>> So you see how the deliberately abusive
>> Um, no, I'm not specifically into abusive stuff. No.
>> So, this is why >> What do you mean by power differential
then, dude? >> It's like there's a like there's a um top
and a bottom. That's what I'm talking about. >> Yeah. In
all, there's a top and a bottom. That doesn't like >> That's
what I mean.
>> Uh-huh. I don't believe, by the way, I don't believe
that's all she means. I think she's gone into explicit detail
on this one as well, and that's not all she
What do you mean? >> And usually And usually when there's
stuff like that's absolutely like an absolute power difference.
Does that make sense? >> I mean, yeah, but like I'm so
confused.
I don't know. I I just like I feel like
you could get power differential stuff out of like so many other
>> Somebody Somebody said Somebody said teacher student
power differential. That is like that is absolute. >> That's
like your topest, >> dude. Dude, it's Sorry. That is
Oh my god.
This is again just the worst answer. The literal worst answer
you could give. The literal worst possible answer and you picked
it. It's like >> it's teacher student things, >> right?
So, so if if it's like teacher student lollycon, right? If it's
teacher student lollycon, then it's like that's super duper.
Yeah. >> It doesn't make it better, but that's >> But
like what I'm specifically into like for example, right, I'm
into petite more
>> That's the secondary characteristics. What is this person?
Like I actually prefer like I actually prefer petites more than
>> Yeah, I like large women so I don't know what to tell
you here. I like giant tessles and Oh, that's going to start
you a drama, isn't it? >> Uh I mean it started drama for
me >> Yeah, I mean h
>> little did Resi realize be perpetual drama for the next
couple years.
Wait, someone in chat said the thing that makes me sound the
most possible. Yeah, I agree with that 100%. That's the abs.
She didn't even say that's that's like what I like. She was like
that's the absolute that's the that's the peak. That's the zenith
is teacher student lollycon. That's the like the Italian you
know the Italian kissing the fingers. That's that's the you can
you can see it right. I'm doing the thing. Yeah. You could that's
it's just the best. It's the zenith. It's the peak. It's the
the best it could possibly get. >> Trying to think. I feel
like other people are curious about your top three. I'm the only
one. The top three is like like Yeah, the top three is not even
[laughter] remotely like actually the top three is don't worry
about it. Okay. >> Okay. Well, yeah. >> Okay. Okay.
Does this at least remove like the um Oh, yeah. You're just faking
it. Whatever. >> Yeah. I mean, I don't think you're I think
you just like >> like I feel like this is like 30 to 40%
of though, right? >> Yeah. No, 100% of is just like weird
power differential. Japanese is crazy. >> And then you
can't tell if that's a child or not anyway. So then you're like,
"Yeah, whatever." >> And that's like the thing. I often
can't tell if somebody's Asian. I just think that they're white
most of the time. >> Yeah. That's what I did IO for like
a year and a half. So I don't know. >> People in chat is
so coping though. Like if you off to like 40% or 30% of the time
in your life, you probably dropped a lollipop. Like what the
[__] >> I mean, here's the thing. Like the
whole school girl shirt thing is still like a aesthetic whatever.
There's so much like >> you know secondary like [__]
that is cooked into it that I'm just like I'm less reacted to
it. Am I going to be like is >> wait what did I'm here
as food shops lawyer and is advised here to shut the up. Kenny
once again. This is Kenny. Kenny once again sweeping for Do we
need We didn't need more evidence of Kenny sweeping for But there
it is. There it is. Kenny again out here sweeping for again.
Kenny's out here again doing it again.
Kenny's about to join the Discord. Go. No. Come on. Food shops
one, bro. Food shops one, bro. It's happening again. >> Is
it cringe? You should stop after foods. Yes, 100%. >> Hold
on. Hold on. the the the amount of times I have debated people
who are into like red pill like I I've had this entire like red
pill arc where I was debating um you know like >> Kenny
is not a hold on I'm not arguing Kenny is a Kenny just sweeps
for because he likes the content that they make probably because
he did this whole thing with food shops from before I'm not calling
Kenny a I wouldn't do that >> the um people who are like
red pill adjacent like not >> I just get annoyed at the
at the sweeping for
red pill but like 60% 70% red pill adjacent and there literally
arguing for like, "Oh yeah, I love my woman, you know, um, like
ripe or whatever the [__] right?" Like, like 20-year-old,
19-year-old, like 18-year-old or whatever the [__]
And like, oh yeah, submissive, incredibly like unable to push
back and like whatever the [__] right? Like what?
Like, what? Like, come on. Like, what really is the big difference
there? I like that's crazy to me. You know what I mean? Yeah.
fair. Yeah. I don't know. I don't really
just like I don't know.
It's abusive. I like watching abusive. I don't know whatever
it is, but it's not it's almost never Have I watched the best?
Yeah, there's this one nurse one was interesting, but um
but yeah, I don't know. >> As Res's lawyer, I advise him
to stop speaking. Okay. >> stop it, man. Stop it, man.
>> I think just like I just think it just gets weird, you
know? >> Um I'll just say like again and again and again
that while I'm not going to judge most people for the things
they're into, I don't need to. no interest. But I I do judge
a little bit the like openness to discuss all of the things you're
into all of the time. It does it just starts to get weird. >> That's
understandable, especially if you're like a bit older. >> I
think res
>> I realized that like I was making fun of Boogie's girlfriend
cuz I thought she was like ugly. And then I realized that I literally
just hate the way that children look and then like I am actually
super unattracted to children. I think they're gross. I think
young people are disgusting, you know? I don't know why. I mean,
I guess cuz I'm getting older, right? But
>> you know.
I see an 18-year-old on the beach in a bikini and I puke. When
I person for me personally, when I see an 18-year-old on the
beach in a bikini, I throw up immediately. I can't even help
it. It's like involuntary, guys. >> Really into a really
thick. >> That's how much of a I am not >> woman.
And some people are like really into a really young woman. >> I
just like I'm old. I just like older. I like like my age and
older at this point. I think it's just like most I mean I I think
I like bimbo aesthetics, but I think that's about it, right?
I think bimbo aesthetics are like the only like younger thing
I can deal with. even then hold on hold on I know people are
calling me like emosi right but you know why >> I don't
know what that [__] means even so >> no because
because there was a um uh Asian person named
>> um and who went to jail prison
>> there wouldn't be like somebody who specifically supported
both of these people and tried to make content with both of these
people right despite being warned by other people about what
they what they were into right there wouldn't be there couldn't
possibly be like a common link between Amosi and food shops
who recently violated probation. >> Um I really I got I
was really hoping really bad to interview him >> um when
he eventually got out of prison. >> Um and uh yeah, now
that opportunity is gone, but um but yeah, he violated
>> He went back to prison. Yeah. Um and uh so um but before
um I had so during the Corontos uh during the Corontos debate
um the infamous the infamous debate um I chugged a lot of um
Parmesan cheese um during that debate because um yeah I was just
chugging cheese for some >> September 16
>> I'm sorry just it felt appropriate okay it felt appropriate
appropriate transition okay I'm sorry [laughter] I can't I can't
do the whole song again right now. Okay. She's just chugging
parmesan for some reason. Okay. >> Like I called it Parmesian
cheese during the entire thing. And um so they came up with a
nickname. Uh Coronto's audience came up with a nickname for me.
Ammo's >> That's weird. That's an odd one. >> So
that's like So basically it's like >> Segway. Fantastic.
>> It's like a little bit of rac It's like racism plus
>> So it wasn't the first time somebody made a nickname
off of Amos.
Huh. Well, I don't think you're But >> and what makes you
think that? I'm
>> primordial tastes resi coping. >> Resi coping.
Oh, I know. Um, no, [snorts] because I can definitely see the
I can definitely see the dominance thing with you and like the
way you interact with people to begin with. So, >> kind
of it just makes sense to me. So,
>> So, we're going through this. So, she's still talking
about the lollycon stuff. He then digs through into my history
and frequency of searching for Okay.
Here, as it is clear in the splice emerge video in the subsequent
day after the talk, Resir shows the clip in the hit piece stream
out of context with no ending of when I answered.
Oh, this could be interpreted either in the most malicious ways,
deliberate lying to complete his narrative that I am a villain
and a liar, which he has explicitly stated in his hit piece or
in the most charitable interpretation that he was lazy and possibly
in a truly sad state of mind. I mean, I think we watched the
whole thing and it still looks really bad. It looks really, really,
really, really bad with the whole context there.
Right. The reason I didn't hear uh it wasn't Oh, right here.
The reason I didn't hear it wasn't actually because of the Discord
audio. Oh, the reason I didn't hear it wasn't actually because
the Discord audio cut out. Well, that would have been a convenient
excuse with nobody to disprove me at all since I was not streaming
with Nova at the time. I will remain truthful here. I heard it,
but I was not listening.
Oh, so never. She debunked the I tried to sweep for you food
shops. I'm sorry. I was I was sweeping without knowing it. I
was sweeping. Okay. I tried but you just you should blew me out.
That's [__] up. I've talked with Sanso before about
this that I might have undiagnosed ADHD. And even though I hear
some words, it is normal to not process the words and therefore
completely miss the question. Thus why I was asking why everybody
was freaking out both in chat and why it seemed like everybody
was anticipating something. Yeah. Uh-huh.
You were asked multiple times, multiple times in a row. He just
kept asking you, you're not a right and you just kept, you heard
it, you heard it and like acknowledged and just deviated away
from the question multiple times too. Like the question was asked
I believe four times and she explicitly deviated away multiple
times to not answer the
Okay. The key is this all about is this some metaphor? The chain,
the key, the lock.
This is like Kingdom Hearts. I feel like it's Kingdom Hearts
for some reason. Keyblades. Okay. Definitely the most controversial
one of all is the
the J Chisel
clips. The recipient on the other end is Jay Chisel, a content
creator who I've feuded with back and forth on Red Pill and other
various issues. We have a have we have had a bridge off and on
and just to debate each other non-stop for weeks on end because
my streams would drag on non-stop. Many of my streams would end
uh end up with me dozing off to sleep and saying very edgy statements
and jokes. While perceptively
this may be seem extreme, I definitely did not mean the things
I said in the clip unironically and was just doing the edgy joking
with J Chisel while being sleepy. If anything, here is me debating
in the past against an Islamic fundamentalist against early child
marriages that I kept as a public video all this time. Yeah,
not shocking you would do this video up here.
Uh-huh. Uhhuh. Okay, we have the J Chisel clips as well. I'm
going to let this play for just a little bit longer. We'll see
if there's anything else here. >> Yeah. Like the way that
like I don't know like these like >> Give me one second.
>> Kind of like romantic interests that you've had in have
always been like some of the weakest willed people I've seen.
You have like a lot of >> really weak people. >> So
Quman So So Quman says, "So you disagree with the video that
makes you a pedo?" Um so from what I know from the stuff that
I read up on >> Oh, I disagree with that too. Yeah. >> No,
hold on. Hold on. So >> yeah, sorry. So I from what I know
that um off to does not mean that you're a pedto but I have a
sus because because you could be so innately into like like you
could be so into that you can just drop off to the law right
um but I have a strong suspicion that a lot of people who dropped
the law are in fact that
>> yeah yeah that would make sense yeah >> yeah and
and a lot of you know a lot of the um pedals that um you know
I did a Q&A with um they absolutely said yeah we all do uh
love con we all we all did you know locon Yeah, you're right.
It's on that one. It's strong correlation, but again, correlation
is not like >> Dude, dude, dude, dude, there's no way she
said that after all of this. >> Quinn was like helping.
I thought Queen was helping before. I defend the person. She's
like, "Yes, I I strongly suspect if you
I again, I've never had the opportunity to go like deeply into
this stuff." So, it's just funny seeing it because all the people
who experienced this content at the time all say the same thing
that her story changes multiple times. It's very clear once you
start watching it that like she is talking. She does have some
genuine attraction there and she's sort of trying to sweep for
it the whole time, right? That once you look deeply into it that
you
will see that like she's clearly there's something going on here,
right? And now I'm I'm like listening and it's like dude, you
there's just no consistency on the answers. keeps like going
I no consistency in the answers keeps contradicting herself keeps
saying things that are incredibly suspicious right about her
consuming and back here she talks about it like a little bit
she's like hesitant to say she does it a lot but I believe there
are other times where she does say she does it a lot >> yeah
I mean a little bit I don't know
>> which is which is why in my opinion we shouldn't discourage
like this kind of like talk or discussion or whatever the like
like my problem is never with um you know uh demeaning people
It's also discouraging like discussion like oh it's like it's
like with discussion in the first place. Um yeah I just I I just
don't like um the meaning discussion of this in the first place.
That's it. >> Yeah. I mean like I think they were like
a really weird you're at a really weird place with it where it's
like
if you what Loker >> I just heard wick. What the >> Yeah,
somebody sent me a link relevant to the combo since we're talking
about
She used to announce that she dropped off to when she would call
in after this combo even
>> from Rhox. There's like a wick thing that came up when
my cat just starts screaming at me. Seek it out like not accidentally.
So, okay. If you specifically are seeking out for the purpose
of Right. >> No. It's about how often it Wait, play it.
Play it. Wait. What's the clip? What's the clip? >> Revant
to this combo. Since we're talking about preferences, resi >> I'm
going to get to where I'm going at. [__] I'm making
my own points. Okay. So, if you're not seeking out for that because
like here's the thing. If you have a thing for like tartan skirts
and like, you know, like that kind of like, you know, Halloween
school girls, does that make you a >> Right. Like, if you're
a dude and you ever off to a chicken like, you know, one of those
tartan skirts with like, you know, white stockings or some [__]
right? I hate I'm not into
>> There's no way he pulls up Britney Spears.
Oops, I did it again. There's no >> that. Okay. Have you
ever watched the porn with something that has something that
is like and then to something that is sexy, you know, pubescent
or anything like that, right? There is a sports bar like that.
Yeah. It's a normal thing. >> Okay. It's like super I understand
that it's weird, but like realistically that's about it. Don't
think about how many women on school girl outfits. Yeah. Yeah.
Ask your girl your girlfriends or wife if they ever [__]
worn one over the age of 18 and like you will be
Okay. So like it's just I don't really feel like I care about
a lot of this >> bootstamps. Tell resi to play the wick
clip. Okay. so bad
here. >> What? What did I say? >> Nothing. It's fine.
I'm sorry. I just realized like cuz like you you need to like
I'm sorry, dude. You need to start like reading philosophy so
you don't learn how to talk, right? Where is he becoming a pologist?
Not something I was prepared for. I'm not a pologist. I think
that anybody who goes out and should be put to death, okay? Period.
>> Oh Jesus. I don't I don't agree with that. What the
>> Yeah, I think rape is worse than murder. >> Oh
god. I remember disagreeing with you on that and everybody else
you >> Yeah, that's fine. People can disagree with me about
I don't give a I think people that are like beyond the bill.
I don't think that I think at that point you are I think that
some people get a taint in their uh if they do like certain actions.
I think some people do become tainted and they cannot be recovered.
I think right among them. >> Why did you say I have to
read philosophy? What the [__] >> So you know
how to talk about the things you want to talk about. >> Wait,
what do I not communicate across? >> I'm just generally
you don't know how to communicate. That's why you're trying to
>> wait in that specific example. >> Because I feel
like this whole thing it's like you're you're like okay. So it's
a dominance thing. >> You're quite literally communicating
to everybody that you're like a this entire time is basically
his point. And he's tired of having to clean up cuz he thinks
despite what he's hearing that you're not a and you're perfectly
communicating that you're ped the entire time and he's like,
"Oh, you need to read philosophy to figure out how to talk."
Very crazy. Very crazy. >> Sex. That's like way different
than me and you know what I mean. >> Wait, but but I do
the [__] >> dude. Oh my god. I can't stand
you.
>> I told you he'd be making this tension headache. Fingers
fingers to his like nose bridge all the time. I told you he'd
be doing it a lot. >> Right. Yeah. That's weird. Do you
still seek it out? >> Go meow meow meow. >> Wait,
no, no, no. Stop. >> wait. Do you seek out specifically
or are you seeking out something that has the aesthetics of >> Now,
I will just say there are a couple people, a couple oilers in
food shops community who have always known about this, who have
always like oiled paid money. Those people are at least as sick,
if not more sick. Okay, I feel like if you could find the list
of like top three or five super chatters to food shops, those
people would be far more deranged than even food shops. Those
people are sick. [__]
Those people are some sick bubbies. All right, you give the subs
to this person. I I feel like, you know, you should be on a watch
list somewhere. Okay. >> What does aesthetics mean? >> Like
the Britney Spears video has the school girl aesthetics.
I'm going to be honest. It is it is if it's if it's literally
like somebody's like a rectangle, it's hard for me to jump off
of that. >> What do you mean if somebody's a rectangle?
like like lack of secondary character uh secondary characteristics
like someone's like actually a kid. Like it's hard. In nine months
after this conversation, we get these tweets. Okay. I can't believe
this cute IRL Japanese girl is in me is in this space and is
actually into me. Okay.
And then there's I'm not into that body type, but I'm not into
kids. I'm Oh, sorry. I'm into that body type. Yes. Sorry. She
explicitly says I'm into that body type. Within nine months,
she's saying I'm into that body type. I am into that body type
with no sexually secondary characteristics. Feel gross an actual
kid, but I'm super into petite like small and small person. So
that's when you say I'm flat as a board. I'm like what's the
issue? H what's the issue guys?
What's the issue?
>> Oh, if they don't have like >> like I'm saying
I'm saying
for me for me I'm into clothing. You know what I mean? Like for
me it's into clothing. Like I really like the clothing. >> So
even the parts here where she's leaning out of this for resi
she's just lying about. Right. Not going to lie. >> So,
you're not searching out. You're searching out an aesthetic,
right? Like, that's what I think it is. >> But you're searching
out because it's most likely that that's going to have the aesthetic
in it, right? >> Wait, hold on. Um,
I wouldn't [clears throat] Well, I wouldn't search up specifically
because that makes me feel guilty. But like, I'm saying like
>> I don't know. >> What do you search up?
>> Well, hold on. That would go into my top three and I
can't do that. >> Cuz I search in my top three. >> And
is that just what you search? What? I don't I don't know what
to tell you here at this point. This went somewhere.
>> it did go somewhere, didn't it?
>> The thing that sucks is like I know what you mean, but
you know what this sounds like, right? Like, you know, like,
right? Like, >> I think I know
[laughter] >> I think I know what you mean, but you know
what you sound like, right? Resi is like begging her to stop.
Just begging her, "Please stop making yourself sound like a Please
stop making yourself sound like a I've been supporting you all
this time. Please stop making yourself sound like a on my stream."
What does it What does it sound like?
Sounds kind of weird. Food. Well, >> no. What does it sound?
No. Specifically, tell me, what does it sound like? >> It
sounds like you are dancing around and trying to bait drama out
of making people think you're a
>> He's still so charitable. It sounds like you're trying
to make people think You're trying to sound like it so that you
bait drama by making people think you're a ped.
Did you figure it out? >> Yeah, I figured this out the
first time we talked. >> Am I? and that's what it sounds
like you're doing and you you you
know that like it doesn't work well. >> It's like they
they actually do have like some kind of brain damage cuz she's
now saying, "Oh yeah, that's what I'm doing. That's what I've
been doing this whole time." And then when she's explaining how
this conversation went here, she doesn't like she doesn't say
that here, right? She's like answering it very ser she's talking
about how it's very serious here the whole time. And now when
Rosie is like, "You're trying to make it sound this way." She
immediately like goes like, "Yeah, I am trying to make it sound
that way. This was all like a joke,
bro. What is wrong with this person?"
Like they actually have some kind of brain damage, right?
Where she just like immediately leans into that as if that's
a thing. Like she if you've ever watched her try to debate somebody,
she does the same thing where she will only get like the only
coherent arguments she ever makes are just chatters giving her
arguments. And sometimes she'll take different chatter's arguments
who are making contradicting arguments and she'll just steal
them and put them together and make a totally convoluted mess.
Like she she somehow can't process information correctly. It's
very funny.
Like she basically has who she can copy, but that's all she can
do. She can't actually there's no synthesis going on. There's
no like light behind those eyes.
She doesn't have she's not been insold. She doesn't have the
spark. It's just not there. Okay. It's crazy.
>> Right? Cuz we talk about that's the other thing, right?
And like the difference between you doing the
versus this one video that I'm talking about with you is that
>> the question no [__] >> You're the
one who's going like, "Oh my god, what what's your what's your
>> Yeah, because I'm trying to figure out if you're like
I'm trying to figure out where the meme ends and you're beginning."
If that makes sense. Right.
>> And like this is like the problem is >> See, that's
See, that's the thing is that it's not a good idea to ask on
stream. Yeah, I understand that. >> Yeah, because because
now when you're asking on stream, that's >> I feel like
you don't make a character who Okay. Yes. But I feel like if
you're making a character for the internet, you probably don't
make it,
right? Like that makes sense. >> But am I making a
Oh, no. I fully believe that she's been answering honestly this
whole time. I'm saying that there's also something brain damaged
here where she can't evaluate like the things she said previously
and how they conflict with the things she's about to say. She
like doesn't have that part of her brain. She's answering honestly
a lot of the time. Like when when they're just talking about
like what kind of what kind of stuff are you into, what kind
of other things are you into? She like she she answers correctly
and then she tries to make it about something else. She tries
to like sweep it up after when she sees the reactions from people.
>> Yeah. But that's the thing >> right now. It sounds
like you are. Yeah. >> Like that sounds like the character
that you're making if that's the case.
>> See Queenman is saying, "Oh, come on. Nobody is buying.
This is all just a meme." See, that's the thing though. ever
said. >> I don't think it's like I think it's like half
I don't think it's all me. I think it's half [__]
meme because I do think like you're trying to be like intentionally
edgy like the rest of
>> cuz like that's the thing you're doing the whole unintentional
edgy thing. It's like you making jokes about back in the >> No.
When you ask >> do you think that you was a summon? >> Do
you know like some of the he said about back in the day? >> Hold
on. You said are you a No.
>> Did I just ask? >> Wait, that's not that's not
actually how that went. He asked if she was a She deflected.
He asked again if she was she deflected. He asked again if she
was there was a long silence. He asked again if she was a then
she says no. That's more like what happened. Okay. >> You
seek out
too long. >> But but it's I I say it's
I said it's I said I
specifically. No. I never type in the keywords in the Google
search engine. >> When you are searching for things of
those lines, what do you type into the search engine? >> Um
the top three.
>> Your top three. >> Dude,
dude. Dude, dude, she literally just admitted she just blew herself
up again. She just bombing her bombed herself again
for no reason. Like her whole time here, she's like, "No, that's
not even in my top anything." And now Resi goes, "When you want
to find, what do you search?" Well, all the things I always search
my top three things. When she said, "I never search for I never
like to this stuff." She's now just admitted that the things
she searches the most are explicitly like finding her. All right.
Uh, dude, I I have no words. I like have no words for this. It's
[__] wild to me. It's so rough to watch.
>> Yes. But but but the top three has nothing to do with
kids. >> Is it like school girl? Is it like school girl
skirts? >> Nope. Nope. Nope. Nothing to do with that. Nothing
to do with school school girls or um anything like that. In fact,
they're completely not even adjacent or even close to Jason.
>> But then that somehow leads you to where you find love,
>> you know. Sometimes, sometimes not
because because by correlation in general um just has a large
amount of stuff. Does that make sense?
>> Do you think all
>> um a large portion of it is? >> I don't even think
that's true. I
Well, I guess it depends on what you mean by a large large portion.
>> So, does that make sense? It's because I love him and
great and I'm specifically into petite stuff. So, if I'm into
specifically petite and I search >> is petite one of the
three. No, I would say I would say probably petite is probably
like sixth or seventh or fifth or something,
>> but it's not top three.
But like but I would say I would say that if I search up top
three, right, and I'm more likely to click on stuff, right? And
I'm more attracted towards petite stuff, right? It's going to
be,
yeah, if you look up petite, yeah, it's probably going to be
>> But that's not a top three. >> Yeah. So, so if
that's going to be happening and I appreciate good art, right?
So, that's what's going to >> You need to stop dropping
off anti- period. Like, I'm sorry. Just >> what? What do
you want me to do? Go to
>> It's a lot of adults there, bro. >> They've got
like rules that that are way outside of my favorites. Okay.
>> But
is it Small Con? >> God damn it.
God damn it, Ruben. Ruben, thank you very much for this three.
Sometimes you want Sometimes you want >> What the?
>> I I I do both.
>> Wait, I do both. Like, what the [__] >> I'm
just >> Wait, I do both. Wait, what?
>> I mean, you're googling it. Like,
>> I don't know. >> Does Does anybody Does anybody
ever just got to the same exact literally every single day forever?
Like, that's so
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> you're so dumb. Most people don't drop off the right
as
>> I would actually
be curious about the numbers on that, but nobody would ever figure
out the numbers on that.
>> Like if if like how many people actually dropped to
>> Can you in food stamps discuss Brianna Woos now deleted
tweets about the Jenny Matrix video? Oh, hold on. Is there any
way that I would still have this album up? Hold on. Let me let
me try entering that URL to see. A
m e w Oh, here we go. Hold on.
I've never talked about this publicly, but I had adults at church
try to me when I was a child in Mississippi. It traumatized me
for a long time. It was part of what drove me to a substance
abuse problem. I do not want to hear a single syllable justifying
child. Two, if you if you tweet justifications at me, you're
we are going to have a fight. This is sick. End of story. I will
not be accepting further moral criticism from people who have
no issue with jacking off to child pornography and not in an
abstract sense. Literally them or their partners jacking off
to child porn. Do not lecture me about morality.
Okay.
Weird. Brianna Woo entrance.
Weird. Forgot Brianna Woo swept for food shops. I thought Brianna
Woo basically said food shops was disgusting. I don't think she
swept for food shops. I thought she literally was like totally
trying to nuke food shops from orbit. I thought might have been
one of the things that helped food shops not get totally content
creator back here.
Brianna Woo. The Brianna Woo curse is really undefeated in every
sense. So if Brianna Woo is against food shops, that might have
everything. Okay. Yeah. >> Destiny should remove these
people from his community. Uh that's literally been suggested
to him and he said no every single time.
Been suggested to him by multiple people multiple times. I know
this for a fact. They've literally said, "Hey, this is really
bad optics at this in our community." And he goes, "No, they're
really helpful. They're really
Okay.
I'm I'm not joking. This is just something that obviously happens.
>> What the [__] Really? Yes. Really? Yes.
Absolutely. Yes. Really? Absolutely. Really, source? Well, I'd
have to leak DMs with people. I'm I'm not doing that right now.
I'm telling you it's true. And if anybody wants to call me a
liar on it, I could prove it pretty easily. Just saying. I could
I could.
In fact, I'm almost certain that people in Destiny's chat have
brought this up to him, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think he's literally said it explicitly.
It's I don't even need to go and Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think Destiny
leaked too much and that's why he's not cutting her off. I think
that would be part of it. Yeah. He also wants people who aren't
going to look at his stuff honestly, who are going to be willing
to lie for him, right? That's why he's talked about how loyalty
is more important than anything else because he needs people
that will lie for him. Otherwise, his whole thing falls apart.
Yes. 100%. >> I don't think this ends well. I think this
is actually that's pretty bad.
>> Oh no. >> He definitely sent food shops to court
transcripts during their perfect memory. Sure. Yeah. 100% he
did. Yep. I don't think that's been resolved either, which is
kind of funny.
There's something weird going on with that case right now, by
the way. I don't know what it is. There's something really weird
going on with that case. I don't know if it's like paused or
somehow something's going on that's just bizarre to me. Like
that there aren't rulings and stuff. I think something very bizarre
is going on with that case. >> I'm not any closer to harming
anybody in our life. >> I just mean I mean there's like
something interfering with them making progress in the case.
I don't know what it is. I think there's something interfering
with progress happening on that civil case. Like the judges for
some reason aren't ruling on stuff. I don't know why, but it's
like the judges have been asked to rule on stuff and they're
going like over deadlines repeatedly. I think any speculation?
No. It's going to court, right? I don't know. They haven't ruled
on any of the any of the motions for like months now. There's
just no rulings coming out >> life. I feel like I'm still
a harmless
>> Yeah. So, >> I feel like um you know um I even
have
harming even the smallest of animals
or >> Was the deadline? I think they had a deadline for
like basically you know there's a 90-day deadline for any motion
to be resolved. And I think they're over that 90-day deadline
for a couple different motions, right? But I haven't I haven't
looked into it a ton. I've not been like following super closely.
I think that's what it is. >> Well, chat, why does this
exist? >> What does what exist? >> You're showing
chat. >> You better not be showing them.
>> Yeah. Do you think that this is going to Do you think
um Yeah, I guess like we're going to go into Lully Discourse
now. That's like another possibility. >> Why would this
ever start up any Do you know how many times Discord have started
up and died in Twitch?
>> Yeah, usually pretty quickly because then they go like
somebody >> Nobody wants to talk about it. Yeah, because
because nobody wants to nuke like a large platform because of
it.
>> except for the smaller pop who wants to g like pedal
clout. Wow. >> What's this? I'm not looking. I'm not watching
that rage. Shut the [__] up. All right, Brianna had
tweets.
What's this? Never talked about this publicly, but I had adult
feed justifications at me. We are going to have a fight. This
is sick. End of the story. I will not be accepting further moral
criticism from people who have no issue with jacking off the
child and not in the abstract sense like literally them their
partners off to child not lecture me about morality. What do
you make of statements here? I think that um regardless of someone's
Trump
>> Okay. Okay. I think I don't really care about Brownoo
statements to be honest, but I think we're almost done here.
I don't know if there's going to be anything else really good
here. Maybe there will be. I'm trying to think, have we gotten
through all the clips yet? Cuz we can go through this and then
we want to finish this this whole thing and then apparently there
was a panel on this
manifesto.
Very interesting. Okay. So, she talks about these J Chisel clips.
these J chisel clips. Let me go find them really quick. We'll
watch them and then we'll continue on with this. Uh we'll continue
on with this. What is happening? Yeah, please go to this. Please
go to this. Thank you.
One clip. Two clip. These are the ones we've seen already. Okay.
These are the ones we've seen already. >> Do you like men?
>> Why are you asking?
>> It was something I wanted to ask like way earlier, but
I don't know if now seems like a question. >> Kind of kind
of sus. >> Oh, what do you mean sus?
Okay, you just don't want to talk about it. That's fine. >> No,
I I like women only.
>> I like women only.
>> Very good. But like trans women, too. Like you'd be
with the trans women. >> Only if they're feminine enough.
>> No, Maximus. I didn't watch that. >> True. That's
mean. >> I don't even I'm not even into They have to have
B. >> Oh, so you don't want to. Damn. You're just like
me for real. >> Yeah. I'm in I'm only into the most feminine
of the most feminine. >> That's what I'm saying. >> I
need to I need to have a little girl to wrap myself around. Uhhuh.
>> Oh, like you're like big spoon is what you're saying.
Oh, I get you. >> I need to have like a 12-year-old. >> What?
That's so crazy that you said that. She wants a little 10-year-old
girl. What the [__] is this known [gasps] or something?
>> Jesus. Okay. Well, there's that. Now, hold on. There's
one more clip from this guy. This is the these are the J Chisel
clips that they're talking about right here. Okay, so she says
she was just really e when these happened. Okay, seems like people
who are attacking me would not put this up as a point in my favor.
Finally, impromptu after J Chisel had been notified of the full
context of what has happened to me without prompting. He has
jumped into spicy chat to defend me. Oh, he jumped into spicy
chat to defend. Let >> me ask you something. So you so
you like masculinity more than femininity in like a partner?
I like femininity.
>> But do you like it more or less than like masculinity?
>> I want a cute little girl that I can wrap my arms around.
>> So, you like being like in the dominant
>> Perfect product placement, guys. Perfect product placement,
boys. We got them. Perfect product placement right there. We
got them. >> It's over.
>> It's over. I was just wondering
>> I was just wondering if if you fit into >> Did
you Did you Did you think that I was the more dominant one or
the more submissive one? Just curious on a more personal thing.
>> Um Well, you said you like masculinity, so that confused
me. But then but now you're saying
what about what about before that? >> Well, yeah. No, no,
no, no. before just now when you said you like masculinity
that I that's why I was genuinely curious because I thought because
you said you like masculinity I thought you like taking on the
feminine submissive
>> okay
do we finish this a little bit here let's let's see where this
goes so this guy jumped into spicy chat to defend her hold on
sub virgins I'm the guy from the food shops I want a 12-year-old
clip number one that wasn't a private call we were both streaming
that's not a defense
That's not a defense at all. That wasn't the question Bubba asked.
Number two, she's not a pedto. And if that's your evidence, plus
that she beats off to animated kids, you definitely need to talk
to your parents. Okay. Well, she was streaming the clip, so I
can't imagine she would be. I can't tell what this is. It's It's
clipped or it's it's cropped pretty tight. Just a heads up at
J Chisel. This isn't our evidence. The clip didn't come from
us, I assume. Cool. And I wouldn't disagree with that. Not a
pedto, though. How did that end up getting leaked anyways? was
streamed, not a leak. Okay. Talk to Resir for the first time
on stream. Heyo, food shops here. Would you be up for a chat
sometimes on stream talking about you and think it would be interesting
to poke at your mind and at you picking up content creation and
me asking about mental health and your sense of morality? Pick
your brain a little. Uh, be casual with me. All right. All right.
Join my server first, though. Okay. I don't know why that's relevant.
Is this Are we into the links portion or not? Hold on. Resir
and I talk about my content at that time. Friendship with Resir
DMs. Resir telling me to save off bad content. You always just
leave and I strongly recommend you do. I love shows to be honest,
but I can't have this every every day. This can only be a once
a month thing. Yeah, so that's the thing. Now that they know
you'll do it, it's going to be what they do daily. They pretty
much harass for platform. I'll stop them. So, I don't know. Your
call, my dude. I'll stop them forcefully. Hard stop if they ask
for it. Yeah, banning them all. Lol. Then for like a week, they'll
call you an epsler and try to bait you. But again, you do you.
Don't worry, I can handle them. Thank you, though. So, don't
worry, I can handle it. Thank you though. Yeah, I mean, it's
less that more. It's less that, more that. Some content is dead
content. Okay. Yeah, for sure. They live for drama only. Yeah,
fake drama. Yeah, Z, I do mean it. I would strongly recommend
not having them on anything. Oh, okay. I'll keep that in mind
then. Thanks, Resir. It's basically like this. Drive pleasure.
That's it. If you're not happy for the content is not going to
work for you being be working for you one way or another. Yeah,
I'm a unique person. That's the thing. The Thorps have one mode
and that's it. Even among other content creators, they don't
have any actual expertise other than being okay with saying slurs.
But I recognize what people kind of people they are as well.
Yeah, but the other people on that panel are not easily intimidated
by them. I don't even know what this is about. It's about some
panel around August of 2023. Okay. It's about the Thorps
on platforming the worst optical discourse. You need more people
that care. Most don't. Laring is content creators. Yeah, unfortunately
that's the case with content creators. Only among like 500 content
creators, you will only have like 10 people who will care, like
truly care. And the 490 sit sub five
Oh well. Uh well, even if they are much more clout, they will
drop you instantly the moment you have no more clout clout clout
left to milk off you. It's just as simple as that. It's sad.
I don't Dude, this is not really relevant at all. I'm not here
to commit careers before I even have a career. A little is okay.
Like those conversations are good for discords but not publicly.
Yeah. Like I'd love to talk about game state functions i.e. Hearthstone
and such MTG because I think those are super neat and translated
conversations. Analyze current field stuff living presently but
again not no real no real interest. But yeah other topics feminism
gender beast ice skirt.
these are the untouchables. Feminism gender. That's very interesting
window to reser's mind right there. I I love resi by the way.
I do love resi. feminism, gender.
[laughter] Okay, fair enough. Fair enough. I actually I feel
like I avoid all of these the same way. I might actually agree
with them through function if not literally. Okay, I might actually
agree with them. I never talk about feminism. I never talk about
gender. I never talk about
so true. It was trying to type there. Beast eye skirt. Why are
you so edgy? I feel like my perception of you is on fire. Lol.
Hey, could you actually take the VOD down? I don't mind. This
is after their conversation. Okay. Hey, could you actually take
the VOD down? I don't mind defending my points, but it would
be annoying if people kept bringing it up on my streaming calls
non-stop. You know, I can't take it down. Like, it would look
beyond horrible to me, and I can't really defend your arguments.
That's fair, and I forgive you. I feel like we're having a disagreement,
and I think I need a bit of time to process it, by the way. No
problem. I understand. My mind didn't hear the question the first
time, November 16th.
Oh, hold on. I feel like this is why they opted out of the Discord
reaction or the Discord the Discord excuse is they told Resi
it wasn't Discord that they didn't process
Sorry, I'm missing I'm reading so I'm missing some stuff in chat.
Oh god. Oh god. Okay.
Gh. Jenny's context on Twitter. Jesus Christ. What is the Jenny
Jenny Matrix had this take. Jesus Christ to this clip. Which
one was this? Twitter. Hello. Twitter. Could you
>> Are you attracted? >> Yeah. I think I think I
literally admitted to this before on stream. Do you think this?
>> Um, no. >> Okay.
Why do you not think it's
>> because um we just watch this?
Okay, whatever. We just watch this. We don't have to watch it
again for like the eighth time.
Uh, bye. Food Chops blocked Jenny
I I only I'm only posting this because my name came up on stream
where this happened. Food Chop said that I already knew she was
into from a previous conversation we had, which is not true.
The debate we had was a 22-minute call where I showed her an
early draft of my video which was 15 minutes long and she gave
her notes including some mild push back to the idea that people
who watch their pedos
the lmao what the bro that's mad yoyo 5 minutes okay she said
absolutely nothing about being a tool yourself what she told
me in VC doesn't even come close to what she said on stream with
resi last night as soon as I heard that it was an instant block
the full context work in progress on copy the offstream debate
on morality on the morality of consuming lollycon in one of the
calls. Did not admit to consuming lollycon personally. Okay.
Anyway, I'm working on my first video. This is going to be all
the Jenny DMs. Huge PDF shops clips. Wait, really? Are we Are
we sure about this? What is
Oh, okay. I did I did see. Okay. I'm sorry, but it does just
it happens again and again and again and again and again. This
is the brand, bro. This is the brand. This is what it is.
This is the brand. I'm I You love to see it. You love to see
it. You love to see it. What's Hassan been doing tonight? I have
no idea. But he keeps winning over and over again. Okay. I I
swear
even if I hated Hassan, which I don't, but even if I hated him,
I would have to admit that he just keeps winning by doing nothing.
Okay. Turns out all the people against him are completely incapable
of not nuking their own reputation constantly.
You see, Asmin defend food shops. No. But are you saying the
food shop's defense was is the food shop's defense just him saying
why does Hassan call
because I think he's probably leaning more into the chibby stuff
and not food
All right, let's continue on with this uh this manifesto
because is this going to be the end? Misque.
When I was thinking of a good back and forth that is truly only
in the banter level, I think of Queen's original hit piece video.
That is was when I thought things were just going to be fine
and when it came to drama. Original video. My response to it.
Sure, he showed my pre-transition photos on his video, which
honestly made me cringe a little bit, but it didn't affect me
much at all. Mainly due to the fact that I already showed them
on stream before. Everything he showed on the video were basically
all things I've shown um basically all shown in public before.
However, what goes too far when it comes to content? I think
short fataku put it best. When the content is taken offline,
instigating drama and fights on the internet are fine. But at
some point, I believe that common sense has now now has to be
used to ask, okay, is this person actually getting pedjacketed
now? I don't believe that to be the case. I I don't believe that
to be the case. I don't believe that to be the case. Pixie dropped
a tweet. Re food shops. I don't know if I trust you. Okay.
H simple simple reminder for any controversy involving miners
of a feather flock together. Wow.
I I hope she's ready for the crash out that this will cause.
I This This is going to cause a massive crash out. Okay. This
tweet is going to is there somebody's going to freak out about
this tweet is going to be the biggest They're going to lose their
mind about it. Okay.
As long as she's ready.
Retweet that. Um this is one of the ones I'm probably going to
hold back from retweeting, but
I get it. I like it. You guys could tweet it. You guys can retweet
it. Okay, go hit that one. Okay,
so where were we here? I think short fataku put it best. I think
I think short fataku put it best, guys. This guy's been giving
me a lot of advice.
All right, when the content is say, oh, sorry. Instigating drama
and fights on the internet. Finds she getting pedjacked. No,
I don't mind when creators and viewers actually try to bring
attention to an issue or a creator who is a legitimate danger
to the space or have enough solid evidence to prove the allegations
they are implying. However, bad faith in concern trolling is
unacceptable. Let's tackle whether this is actually the case.
Queen and Cot and Son Souls live stream red-handed. I don't care
if someone looks at Grooming actually hurts someone. I don't
have one. It's just funny.
Uh, finish the VOD. I'm in an Overwatch game. Not much longer.
J Chisel from here. Jumping into spicy chat of his own valition.
Defending me to clarify things. Get slandered instead. Is this
the same logs we already looked at? Deleted.
Album deleted. Chad Logic with at least 28,000 subscribers covering
me telling people to keep their distance then says they are not
canceling me. Name drops Bug Swander and Queen also banned somebody
from chat calling out his strong lack of strong positioning.
Segmented. So this is a YouTube video and then segmented compilation
of Tread Logic saying he's not canceling me but repeatedly saying
he wouldn't go on my platform or associate with me knowing I
am a very small compared to him and he has a larger reach.
unfortunately that's you have to deal with that, right? You do
have to deal with that. I
I It's hard to blame Chud for this one. No. Is it not?
Why' she even include that in the manifesto? I have no idea.
Me going hard against an Islamic fundamentalist in a debate on
the age of consent months ago. Skipped over entirely by literally
everybody covering the drama. This video is public the entire
time. I don't think these things are mutually exclusive
there. You could wait. Why does she pretend that this could be
why why is she pretending this would be dispositive of being
a Why? That's not that's not even dispositive of her being
could easily argue against the age of consent being lower. That
doesn't make any sense.
Me having a good faith conversation with somebody from Karanto's
community. I'm I say we should stigmatize certain bad acts but
not other acts and draw differentiations allowing room for nuance.
Once again, public video that was skipped over entirely. Lack
of charitability.
Okay.
Dead logic. Dave drops queen and bugs wander. people digging
into me. Says he is doing something good for the community. Later
on gets mad when other content creators aren't taking advantage
of the easy clout and content. Is this up still? I'm guessing
this is down. Video not found. Yeah.
Spicy chat and Chud getting very upset. Will this album still
be here? What is this? Twitch bowl has never been more over.
Some [__] tier panel host says they like Lolly and
no one even asked them about it. LMFAO. Back in the day, people
have been all over that. Lol. Nowadays, you'd be auto accused
of
held a panel last night with which Stardust and Tom participated
in. They 100 100% know what's going on. NSA was supposed to be
on, but but she mysteriously dipped, but apparently not because
of this. Food stamps is also now calling the video she's making
uh calling the video she's making to address this a manifesto.
Okay. Jesus, man. What did Tom/ Stardust say about the Jenny
Matrix video? The stuff. I'm not sure Stardust has watched it.
Tom shrugged the stuff off. To his kind of credit, he did say
that the video was mediocre and should have focused primarily
on the discord grooming, etc.
This just seems like such wasted content opportunity for them.
Absolutely. Both from a Skevie perspective, but also the fact
Res's VOD has a great slanging match between Queen and Beckett
and Samantha Savage. I think a good chunk of this is an automatic
dismissal due to spicy chat association. They'll bury their head
in the sand cuz they're both still butt hurt. Dude, that is so
insane to me. I don't even look at other streamer Discords. How
can you care so much about a channel, a single channel, which
at this point has like 10 to 20 regular users? I I usually call
Chut out on this one that people shouldn't care about Spicy.
Spicy punches above its weight like pretty significantly. Okay,
pretty significantly.
It I think even more before. Now it's like now it's not the same,
but before it punched like very significantly above its weight
in terms of things that would like affect Twitch pole in the
space in general.
The oh, it's just 20 UNKS. I I'm always like, no, it's not. Not
for people who are like very very egotistical there. There's
just a lot of people who can't handle the constant jabs at their
ego. And that's why spicy chat gets the rep it does. But it also
causes people to totally spiral like all the time, right?
Like if you sit in there and you just get poked over and over
again. Some people will just totally spiral on that
and then they That's content. I guess
happens a lot. Oh Jesus.
Oh, this is the Parseek stuff. Oh, there's a she did a video
about DGG canceling her, too. I don't think I would have checked
out that content. I super don't care, but
interesting. Rose saying he could help Queen out with a minor
with minor video editing related to stuff after covering Queen's
first hit piece on me before the drama blow up. I don't know
what that's supposed to be about. Oh, just not getting charity.
Keeping it real
This is actually afterwards, I think, like an afterward for the
whole piece. I like telling the truth and I try to be as genuine
as possible when I'm out here streaming. My style isn't for everyone
and my humor isn't for everyone. But that's okay. I already understood
what that or I already understood that when I entered the stream
sphere. However, there will always be trolls and there will always
be people who try to point out or try to paint bad narratives
of other people for the sake of content. I don't mind the existence
of them because I regard them as more of a force of nature. Just
like other forces of nature, you have to build shelters against
them with sturdy foundations with people you could trust. Okay.
Haha. [laughter]
We've reached the I
I feel like I'm trying to think
who's the guy who wrote the tipping point.
Why can't I think of Malcolm Gladwell? This is like some Malcolm
Gladwell writing right here. Okay. Logic goes out the window.
Charitability becomes a minimum. Oh, sorry. What truly shatters
that foundation is when you let bad conversations dominate the
space. Logic goes out the window. Charitability becomes a minimum.
And friendships mean nothing. It isn't what I'm surprised. It
isn't that I'm surprised by spicy chat or Chudlogic sphere because
they exist with no moral principles and only for the sake of
any kind of content and clout as I never really expected much
from them and my expectations are at a minimum but
expectations are at a minimum but rather I set expectations for
people like Resir who I expected to part with me quietly or at
least talked with me in private before doing so. Instead, streamers
who I believe were charitable invited in the bad actors to infest
the story, disregarding content I've had up on the channel since
before our friendships that argue against enabling and grooming
related actions.
Hold on. I She makes the differentiation herself. I truly believe
she's like a like a in terms of her attraction. I don't believe
that I'm saying I'm not saying that she's a kid. We all understand
that, right? When we're calling her a We're not saying you a
kid. I know that cuz I would call the cops, right? We're saying
we believe you are attracted to minors, to like young people,
characteristics even. Can you prove that? I'm I'm saying that
she has talked about being attracted to these characteristics.
She's talked about being attracted to the power dynamic. She's
talked about being attracted to people who are underage. She's
talked about being attracted to like an IRL. Okay. Okay. Sorry,
I wasn't sure, Spruce Bos, but yes, I do think there's a lot
of things that add up here and lead us to that exact finding.
Okay.
Huge clip for food shops. I don't think it is. I think you're
you're what? I see what you're doing, Verane. Okay, I'm opening
it myself first. Oh, I don't know if I can do this one.
I don't know if I can do this one. I think this one is What is
this one? Is this one of the ones that came from Is this one
of the ones that came from her private conversations that got
leaked? There's no like her.
It's just her talking. What is the clip? What is the clip?
It's not No, it's not that. Okay. Okay. Well, I was just going
to make sure first. Okay, we'll watch it then. What is this ultra
rare clip of not food shops saying being a pedto is so what?
>> Dude, I swear to God, like
will be like, "Oh, X is a it's like
and
and and
what what
afterwards? Do you do do you go after them? Have you reported
to the police? Have you have
>> again they know the difference? They obviously know
the difference between offending and not offending anything about
it. And also it's like okay all right have they done anything
like have they like tried to solicit news for minors? Have they
have they ex
bro? I I can't, dude. It's just the space is >> cuz that
would make them truly monstrous if they solicited and or and
then kept, you know, videos of my >> stupid crazy. >> The
space is actually so stupid. Like, okay, great.
It's like it's like, oh yeah, it it's like kind of saying, oh,
you're a man. You're you're a straight man. It's like, well,
yeah,
you're a straight man. You're you're a straight man. Okay. Does
that Does that mean that you're going to go out and rape a woman?
Right.
It's not the same. Okay. Show me. Show me. Where's the difference?
It It's an attraction that can be carried out in a violent manner
that isn't being carried out in a violent manner. It could or
could not be. Right. We give men the benefit of the doubt. We
actually have solid statist Okay, so she is actually laying out
the difference between these two things.
Actually trying to make it seem like it's not that big a deal
to be a in the first place. I
like Okay, I
h
you don't call the cops. I don't know why she did the call the
cops bit.
I do think I do think that they've got that attraction and they
are that's why they're so personally >> for men
and people are just like
they're just ignoring they they're >> just to be clear
there is a there is a healthy society accepted dynamic between
men and women. There's no healthy society accepted dynamic between
anybody any adult and a child.
Right? That's that's the difference. That's the obvious difference.
Go ahead. >> Oh, yeah. Yeah. You know what? You know >> Well,
I'm sorry. I'm correcting her what she's saying.
>> Burden of evidence.
We're not going to find out
what percentage of
go after kids,
but we do know the statistic of how many men go after women.
And we're going to freak out more over the pee. It's just
Please,
please just kill yourselves. Just kill O. That's a That is a
rough
That is a rough clip right there. That is a rough clip right
there.
Oh boy. That's uh [sighs] I'm not a And you're transphobic and
anti-Semitic for saying I am. But also, what if I'm a Anyway,
yeah, that's I'll like all those. Sure. Sure. We can like those.
We can like all those replies. Those are good replies. Anyway,
okay. So, she's complaining about spicy chat here.
I think I think you're getting insight into why she decided to
take up Destiny's side in this whole thing,
Like I I think you're getting a lot of insight here. She She
thought these people like destroyed her and so she was going
to go back in the other direction here. I think that's like really
just looking into the psychology of why she decided to just go
take Destiny's side without looking at any facts, just being
a totally like disingenuous lying rat the whole time. It's It's
just that it's pretty obvious.
Okay, where were we here?
Arguing against enabling and grooming related actions. So, I
I could even believe that she's against um having sex with kids,
like actual kids. I just think the attraction is there pretty
obviously. You didn't really need deep digging through kickods
to find that her her advocating against, you know, harmful action.
I would recommend that the next time before people try to pull
a pedto implication piece or cover the talk and apply direct
judgments on my character from a place higher than spicy and
chud logic's community that they would at least do their bare
minimum due in due
You're saying it's not a character attack. You're saying that
calling you a that's that's not anything. It's just a normal
attraction. So it's not even a character attack in your opinion.
They took they took upon them to cover the drama, the details
and the spicy bits without looking for into it further. Hit pieces
slander my name. Yeah, because we could literally just grant
you the other stuff, right?
We can just grant you that you've argued against the actions
doesn't change the other statements. Hippie is slandering my
name in public and damaging my reputation in the space for the
sake of maybe some performative clout. As a new content creator
entering the space, I am vastly disappointed by what has transpired
and has hurt my sense of trust, especially when it comes to making
new relationships with streamers or and other creators in the
space. Is this really the charitability, good faith, welcoming
Matt that you want to put forth to newcomers? Even now, I still
f can't find hatred or anger in my heart. Only some sense of
sadness that things turned out this way. Regardless, we have
to move forward. And with this, I close this write up. Descent
consent collection.
Destiny short fat otaku.
Wait, what's the dev tweet?
What? What's the dev tweet though? Okay.
Said absolutely nothing about being I don't know the details
on this story, but I'm not into and I'm not into myself. I just
think it's a bad idea to treat drawings the same as actual Z.
I wouldn't cut somebody out over their preferences if nobody's
hurt by them
I think there's an issue of talking about this stuff and and
like trying to normalize. There is there's something I don't
like about that that is there.
yeah, there's just
because you can't label a direct harm. I think it's pretty spooky
to just say something's fine. I don't know. There's there's something
here where I I like reject this argument and I have a hard time
putting into words precisely why I reject this argument sometimes.
Okay.
mostly because in this case specifically because I think dev
is trying to get like um pictures or some favors out of this
which is what really puts me off but but other than that I think
the argument itself if I didn't know that dev was trying to become
was trying to get gratification out of doing this I would still
be put off by it there's something else there
um absent dev's obvious attempt to get some kind of second gratification
from this okay son Smith
okay I I believe Queen said this.
Need everyone who is in a law enjoyer to please stop coming to
my chat. I only associate with law enjoyers.
Tom's on some man. Tom's on some I think it's simple. Simply
there could be some unhealthy dynamics even if there's not harm
direct or indirect. That's how I'd word it. Possibly there's
probably something else I could, you know, try to figure out
here.
It is certainly offputting. I understand. I understand that being
off-putting isn't necessarily enough every time. Okay, I get
it. I do get it. Wait, why are people spamming cankle more in
the chat? Is did that come up? Oh, right here. I I got it. What
happened to that guy? That guy's out of here, I guess. Okay.
All right. Without further ado, I think that Listen, there's
there's more food shops content we could do, right? We could
watch that Krontos debate. We could watch some of the stuff later
with Brianna Woo. Okay. There there are things we could watch
after this that are very interesting and very funny. Here, hold
on. Where are we looking? Where are we looking? Oh, there is
the Andrew Wilson debate which is pretty funny. I regret debating
this person, this crazy person. >> Okay, sure. So, uh the
way I define uh patriarchy, uh patriarchy is a social system
in which uh positions of dominance and privilege are primarily
held by men. Um the way I do define dominance is uh power and
influence over others and privilege is a special right, advantage
or immunity granted or
>> only to [laughter] a particular person or group. And
um you know uh so conservative And yes.
>> Okay. So, um, when it comes to >> the I think
what they start laughing at her for is she's got a roll of toilet
paper sitting on her floor back here.
>> A special right advantage or >> you just admitted
primarily held by men. You lose.
>> Well, I [laughter] mean, I available only. I said available
only, right? I said available only. >> Patriarchy, right?
Already. And you say people are getting happier. That's awesome,
bro. I mean, which I mean, which which part which part do you
do you particularly dispute here, right? Like like you you didn't
know which which one like you you particularly like dispute.
I don't get it. Like >> what's there to dispute? Here's
your
>> I think according to you, you say societyy's getting
happier and then you gave a definition of patriarchy. And in
your definition of patriarchy for why patriarchy is bad, you
say it's because the positions of authority are primarily held
by men. But in all these happy societies you point to, all those
positions are primarily held by men. Therefore, all those societies
Shut up. Let me finish. Therefore, all those those societies
have to be patriarchies by this definition. That's it. That's
the argument. You're done. >> Yeah. But your argument is
that we necessarily need a patriarchy, right?
>> Is that
my argument? You're pivoting, bro. You're the debate's over already.
>> No, no, no. My argument from here. My argument, my argument
is that as we're moving away farther and farther from a patriarchy,
things tend to generally become better, right? >> That's
my
Wait, wait a second. Back up.
>> you you are admitting that we exist in a patriarchy
and people are getting happier, right?
>> This is He really does just have one
>> He didn't even to be fair in his defense, Boots lost
the debate before getting to force doctrine. Okay. So, he does
only have one debate, but this is actually a different debate.
We didn't even get to force >> under your definition is
just that most of the positions of enforcement and positions
of power.
Can I peel? So then I can at least finish what I'm saying. >> Okay.
Go ahead. Go ahead. >> Yeah. Okay. So, yes, I can understand
that we live in a patriarchy, right? But then primarily if positions
of dominance are held by men, right? Sure, I can agree that positions
of dominance are held by men. But then it seems like these kinds
of systems where men are holding more dominant and leadership
positions are becoming less and less more important, right? They're
becoming less and [laughter] less important. Meanwhile, we can
see, you know, rates like, okay, women going to colleges are
are like rising, right? Um, women are becoming more and more
prominent. Like, for example, women in politician roles are like
rising up, right? >> All that's happening. Wait, let me
finish. Let me finish moderator. Can I appeal to the moderator?
>> Okay, listen. Listen, [clears throat] you can finish,
but try not to go on too long because this is an open dialogue.
>> Sure. Sure. Okay. So, so we can we can basically see
women in leadership positions like um taking up, you know, taking
up leader uh leadership positions, right? And you know, just
overall it just seems like to me that the you know, we really
don't need men in patriotic position. >> So, it seems like
to So, it seems like to you that the benevolent patriarchy is
allowing all these women to have all these great and and wonderful
positions within society and that society's most key positions
are Shut up. It's my turn. I didn't interrupt you. Shut up. >> He
did let you finish. >> Shut your mouth. You're saying that
you just love and adore the fact that society right now exists
under a patriarchy by your own definition and it's so benevolent
that it's even letting these broads who it could oppress if it
wanted to uh do all these great and wonderful things and it's
making society happier. Well, I mean that's awesome man. >> Okay,
so I'm going to finish. Okay, so the problem with that is that
obviously um your what is what is your appeal? How is it that
your your assumption >> so I don't think any function of
the patriarchy in in Andrew's view means that like men always
make decisions over women or something like that? I don't think
that's ever been a part of his like definition of this.
So that's what she's I I think she's trying to hint at some idea
that like well if if patriarchy were good then all men would
need to have all positions of power or all men would need to
be above women or something, right? And it's like no that would
be a really stupid argument. In fact, it would just be obviously
wrong like on its face. So it's probably not his position because
it's obviously wrong on >> is that men is letting women
um allow in these positions. Is that correct? >> Okay.
I would argue that it's not specifically a case of gender. I
my I would actually say that it is more of a case of power, right?
For example, what is to there are lots of women leaders, right,
that are in positions of power, but it's not to enforce their
authority. >> Yeah. But but it's not it's not a particular
case. It's always the case. It's not a particular power.
For example, how how do you how do you explain a way that women
judges are basically locking away men to death sentences? Then
how does that make any sense to you? >> What does that
have to do with anything? They are appaling everything to do
with >> Yeah. Judges judges are not the enforcement harm.
That would be the
>> Let me finish. I I'm counting you
You have to stop talking. >> We got there.
Okay. >> No. Judges have to appeal to police officers and
they have to appeal. >> Oh, they actually they did food
shops such a favor. This is actually such a sweep, dude. Food
shops lose their mind in this debate after this. Like there's
only two minutes left. She was like I want to say she was screaming
for like five or 10 minutes or something like she just starts
spuring out. >> They have to appeal to all of these different
people to actually enforce their will. Judges do not make a ruling
and then go enforce it, do they? Who >> play the chimp
out? Well, I don't. We're getting to the chimp out or we must
be. But I dude, it's like not here. >> Would you say primarily
the that enforces a judge's ruling would be male or female if
you had to guess? >> Okay. Sure. The thing is I can totally
understand is that at the end of the day, sure, the people who
hold a right are absolutely male officers, majority male officers,
right? But the thing is is that at the end of the day, physical
strength um at least in modern society is not a big deal anymore.
That's the thing, right? Because at the end of the day we have
right because isn't the whole point behind like conservatives
is that are the great equalizer between physical strength right
because if a woman can handle a gun correctly right can't a woman
a man be dumb you know in Indiana Jones you know like that one
scene where like the one guy was like waving around the sword
and then Indiana Jones like the guy and he just drops dead right
the thing is that sure WOMAN JUDGES I CAN'T I can't do [laughter]
it
I can't take it I don't want to hear it from a four
like when Indiana Jones got his whip and
the argument. Okay. Argue fallacy numero uno in the performative
politics debate
Argument from okay argument from and its consequences have been
disastrous for the entire debate. >> Remember when Indiana
Jones
you debate you debate like a [laughter] you debate you debate
like a for you look like one too. Okay. So let me finish my point.
Let me finish my point. Let me finish my point. Sure it's true.
Sure it's true. Sure. Sure, it's true that female judges, Sure,
it's true that female judges have to at the end appeal to a majority
a majority male police force in order to bring the murderers
to prison. I totally agree with that. >> So, the foundation
of society is patriarch. Let me finish. Let me finish because
because at the end, but at the end of [laughter] the day, but
at the end of the day, it just seems to me that's not the kind
of society we're living in anymore, right? >> We live in
that society right now.
>> Dude, it actually cuts off as she goes to spra. If anybody
has the rest of this, I don't have the rest of this debate. I
this debate might be lost media. If anyone's got the rest of
this debate, I would love to see it, but I it might be lost media.
It might be gone.
Andrew Wilson, if you can hear me, can you hear me? Andrew Wilson,
can you hear me?
I'm calling on you to release the full debate. Andrew, release
the full
Release it. Release it now.
Okay.
So, I don't have the full version of that. I don't know if there's
anything else in the food shop. And we've got a couple other
things we could do here tonight. Okay. Okay, we've got the Tactical
Templar video on Noxaku. We've got an Epstein video from the
Silly Serious. Okay, we got both of these. And then I might watch
this Majin video on
I got rid of it. But there's a Majin video on the Kaiday 10 stuff.
That could be funny to look into. Okay. All right. All right.
All right. Krontos debate. The Krontos debate is just going to
be the whole thing in the Krontos debate is her saying she likes.
So we could watch the Krontos debate. It's going to be dog [__]
though. It's all going to be dog [__] Can we get
a poll for it? No. I'm saying these are the things I have left
to do. Uh you I could give you a poll, but then I'm not going
to follow the results of the poll anyway. So
unlucky.
What is this? Is uh food shops from tonight? Okay, hold on. Food
shops from tonight. No way. >> That's what I'm saying.
>> I need to I need to have a little girl to wrap myself
around.
>> Oh, like you're like
big spoon is what you're saying.
The um the context for this specific joke was more than three
years ago and
uh me and my friend at the time would do shock jock humor. Both
me and him.
>> Can you show me some videos of him doing um like humor?
Can we see that? Can we see that? Can we see that? maybe >> would
come up with things
that would each other off
or to >> I don't even know that she made that argument
in the manifesto. She said in the manifesto that she was falling
asleep and so it was shock jock but she was falling asleep. She
didn't say he was doing it too >> the other person. >> Or
maybe she did. I actually don't remember but it it seemed to
be that she was falling asleep. She didn't she wasn't aware of
how bad it was because she was falling asleep >> basically.
Yeah. on purpose, which is why it's also said in a very monotone
voice. Okay.
If you actually go and watch because I'm pretty sure >> Oh,
she So, she's saying it was a in a monotone voice because it
was a joke because it was shock jock humor. She said it was like
like that because she was falling asleep before. So, that was
another It's a second excuse. New second
Okay. Found a reaction debate by a non-Lolly VTuber without the
chimp out or with with the chimp out included. Okay. society
like as athetical is that
jobs as servers and child [clears throat] care.
>> Holy [__] Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. We got to finish this. We got to finish this one first. The
co-pier first and then we'll go to that one. See you later, Kuryoko.
See you. See you. See you see you. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. >> If
you actually go and watch because I'm pretty sure people have
>> Oh, this guy used to be a mod in the chat and now he's
literally sweeping for the unlucky. unlucky man. >> Alo
the old streams. If you actually go >> that's kind of >> and
watch the old streams. All right, you'll see that I'm not lying.
But you know, you know what's kind of crazy is that I I don't
even know if I want to judge
anybody
um based off of allegations that they've had 3 years ago. Okay.
I I don't even know if I want to if I want to judge anybody by
that, you know, let alone um >> Here's the clip. Here's
the clip. Here's the clip. let alone things I've only said, but
no actual victim is coming out against me
from almost three years ago. That that makes no sense. >> This
is uh this is her trying to copy the the Destiny response to
the non-consensual recording thing with the Grinder hookups.
Why would you guys accuse me of a crime here when nobody's coming
out as a victim? She's trying to copy that. But the actual thing
we're accusing her of is the primary attraction, right? The the
attraction she has. That's what we're accusing her of. We're
not accusing her of victimizing somebody,
And she understands the difference between these two things.
She
Two things are important to note here. Not all have victims.
So the scope of what she's doing. Yeah. Exactly.
Boot shops as recently as a month or two ago was saying she likes
drawings of child telling people if they don't like that about
her then they can leave because she can't change her attractions.
Those attractions of course being children. got a little kid
right here at this exact moment in time. When when she's confronted
with the I of course, guys, of course, when she's confronted
with the IRL version of her, you know, anime fixation, the IRL,
she immediately goes, "That's totally disgusting, right? That's
totally disgusting. I could never. I could never. That's totally
disgusting." Wait, I I closed the I'll find it again. Oh, right
here. Yeah. No, this is it. Wait, no, it's not. It's not, actually.
It's um it's I can't believe this cute IRL Japanese girl who's
in this space is actually into me. I think I must be getting
catfished.
Yeah, she sure she turned it down immediately. Oh, wait. No,
she didn't. Oh, wait. No, she did not.
No, she did not. She did not turn it down. Now, that's just the
person who looks like that. As far as I know, she didn't think
this person was 17 at the time. But what she's attracted to is
the look, right?
The characteristics, the the person who looks like this, who
acts like this. And I believe this person does that as well.
They did a whole lar as like a little girl as well. Okay. Okay.
Anyway, back to the clips. I think there's another clip there
in the substance clip. Where is it? Where did I Oh, right here.
Oh, >> unironically obviously because of that, right? And
then I also admitted at some point that I unironically consume.
So, if you don't like the fact that I
>> you're free to leave. Okay.
um you know like that is just a part of me you know like it's
it's not like I can change my attractions or anything like that
right but I don't think I'm a I really don't think so >> it's
just the that's the weakest disavow that's the weakest like distancing
of those I just really don't think I'm a guys I just like you
know hard to be certain about these kinds of things but I just
don't think so I just don't think so okay all right kind of weird
bro kind of weird
okay that's without Without anything else, I believe that's the
end of the manifesto. Manifesto has been completed. We're done
with the manifesto.
We've watched this clip. That clip. Was there something else
I'm waiting to get to here?
Oh, did I have something else here? Yeah. No, I don't think so.
Looking around. Looking around.
I can't tell if there's other stuff I need to get into here right
now.
H Oh, right. No, no, no. The uh the spur out. The total chimp
out. Give me a second. How How could I forget? How can I forget
the Andrew Wilson totally totally springing out right here. All
right, we're going to watch this in that
exact [__] Shut up. Shut up. >> Shut up and
let me finish, bro. >> I just want to I just want to say
for the audience. I just want to say for the >> Stop talking.
>> This is the same.
There's no moderator right now. >> Stop talking. Stop talking.
>> Thank you, [laughter] by the way, for that clarification
earlier. Okay. What do you want me to do? I'm just disappointed
more than anything. >> One more time. Child care specialist
is what I pointed to. >> I debated for years, Andrew. >> And
you suck at it, bro. You're terrible at it. So, one more time
with the child. >> Disappointing. Come on, Andrew. >> Child
care specialist. >> Oh my god. >> What's a child
care specialist? Would a mom be a childare specialist? >> Oh,
what? You found one example out of the five of them. Congratulations.
>> It's in the top five of THEIR JOBS, BRO. >> AND
WHAT ABOUT HOW ABOUT medical record specialist? Andrew keeps
calling her bro. Again, is
is this a dude or is this just an ugly female?
Anybody watching this, please enlighten me on that.
>> Well, let's look and see.
>> Transwoman. It's transwoman. Okay, those kind of [__]
up
is >> You want to You want me to list male jobs now? Because
you told me to search that up. Brick mason, stonemasons. Wow.
Unabonga,
heavy vehicle mechanics. Oabonga cring AND TOWER OPERATORS. OABONGA
AUTOMOTIVE body repairs. OABONGA
MISS MISCELLANEOUS VEHICLE [laughter] EQUIPMENT AGAIN. OABONGA.
OH MY GOD. OH DESTROYED.
HOLY.
>> Give her the air horn. What? >> Sorry. Hold on.
Sorry. I
I just I'm a little disappointed here personally that we don't
have the DGL plushy somewhere in this frame. It really belongs
here and it's just not here. And it does actually make me a little
sad. You got you got obliterated. So So I I just had I'm sorry.
>> Which of those two groups do you think would be more
capable of enforcing [clears throat] their will on somebody else
if they chose to? >> This is my Parmesian cheese. Oh yeah.
This is my Kiran. [laughter] Sorry. >> These are my Marbor
Reds. This is my >> Yeah. Yeah. No. No. No. Wait. Wait.
What alcohol? Wait, wait. What alcohol? What alcohol? What alcohol
[laughter] do you drink? Wait. What alcohol do you drink? What
alcohol do you drink? No. No. Seriously. I No. No, no. What?
What brand do you drink? [laughter] >> That'll be why Andrew
doesn't have this stuff up anymore. Okay, that's a no no on YouTube.
>> Um, it's called Anti-Sp. >> Oh, Antisburg. Oh,
me too. I love
>> Anything else you >> What was that? >> I
love [laughter]
>> What was that? Like intentional gibberish there or >> anything?
Me, too. I love [laughter]
>> What? Anything else you wanted to add? >> Yeah,
you got owned by other well other points. Yeah, I got obliterated
>> when you started jumping up and down and screeching
at the top of your lungs. That was my favorite part of my owning.
>> Andrew, you are
>> come on. Andrew, you Listen, I This is so [laughter]
Oh my god, you're so
>> Uh, if I could just step in for a >> Wait, you
you relinquished your mind powers. I >> I'm not going to
moderate. I'm actually not going to moderate. I'm actually Hang
on. I'm actually [laughter] not going to moderate. It just >> shots
here is a genius. >> It actually just appears that Andrew
is getting fed up. So, I just like I want to step in. I want
to ask you >> fed up since the very beginning. Come on,
Zen. Come on. >> I want to ask you [laughter] uh like >> you
understand that society could function without dental hygienists,
right? Like it could like >> Well, then your teeth will
be IT'LL BE LIKE GEORGE WASHINGTON'S teeth all yellow and buckled
and [__] You know what I mean? You hear me talk?
>> But but how would how do you think society like as it
stands today would function without like running cars? Like
>> is this like racism? Is she trying to
>> I can't tell. Is this like an accent or >> Well,
how do you think society today would be as good of a QUALITY
OF LIFE WITHOUT dental care? What the how how often do you go
see the dentist?
>> Not very often. I haven't been >> THAT'S WHY YOUR
TEETH IS LIKE THAT
OH MY [screaming] GOD. OBLITERATED.
Oh my god.
>> Are you done?
This is so cool.
I'm I I have a very hard time even like What do you even say
to add to this?
I don't know what you say to add to this. I like actually can't
add to this at all.
Who came first, Darius or Food Shops? I don't know.
I don't I don't know. I don't know what this is. >> One
B2. I can one me to you guys. Okay, >> I can one me to
you guys. You guys [laughter] You guys are small pride to me.
Okay, bring up Destiny. Where's Destiny steel maning your position?
>> I didn't even bring up the statistics. [laughter] We
can't even go to philosophy. Okay, what is a util? What is he?
I can't believe I watched like 50 hours OF ANDREW. I CAN'T BELIEVE
I WATCHED 50 hours of Andrew for this. This is ridiculous. I
I I CAN'T BELIEVE HOW MANY HOW MANY OPPOSITION research that
you actually did on me. You look like a fourth freight gay star.
LIKE I FOUNDED THE SIX PAGE OF AND YOU LOOK LIKE THE EXTRA of
like the teenage like like like
Hold on. Hold on. Stop.
>> What is that part? You can spur out. But that was like
borderline TS. >> You got me crying over here laughing
>> He's crying right now, bro. Here is Zen. Here's Okay,
Zen, you're Andrew. Andrew, listen. I love you, okay? Zen, I
I mean, I mean, Zen, I mean, got me crying, bro. Listen, you
guys are mixing together into one person. Okay. All right. >> No,
no, I'll step back out. Go ahead. >> Oh my god. Hard. [laughter]
I I think I drank too many energy drinks. So,
[snorts]
>> okay. Wait, I'm going to write some points down. And
how about this? I did a lot of research for this debate. Okay.
um over 50 hours. >> Why not? I I believe in >> clearly
didn't want to engage in it. I mean, lost it in 10 minutes. I
don't even know what the [__] point of the debate
was. >> Well, [laughter] you see, I believe in intellectual
discourse and I believe >> when you jump around screaming
at the top of your lungs. >> I believe in the of academic
studies. [laughter] I do. So, so listen, um we can go into it
um basically point by point. Okay. So, >> so there you
have it. the debate more or less where we have a liberal totally
melting down.
[clears throat] >> So I think for the rest of that debate,
Andrew basically just mocks her, right?
That's not the whole thing, but I think after that, Andrew just
mocks her until she eventually leaves. They might even kick her
out. Like I think Andrew basically just goes, "This person's
a total loser. Get them the [__] out of here." He
just keeps mocking them. Starts talking about how their room
is. Look at how up your entire set is. It's kind of [__]
up, man.
She literally acts the way Rob No describes a leftist. I'm sure
she does. Yes. I'm sure they got a lot of laughs out of this.
Was very helpful to them.
All right.
Now, the biggest crime here is that I unfortunately didn't finish.
I grabbed some food real quick to try to eat while we're watching
that spur out. It didn't last long enough. Man, didn't he offer
$500 to clean her room or something? I He did something like
that. He did something like that. Yeah, it was very funny. Okay.
All right.
Wait, what? No. No. No. Stop. This is
Wait. What was this with resi? This is 2025. Why was this over
new PDF allegations? This is in February of This is last year.
>> I know you're not going to >> I didn't notice
the timer on this or the the date on this. This is last year.
>> No, I do.
>> Kronto says the Kronto is going to suck. I'm telling
you, it sucks. It is just going to suck.
I'll give you the link. Not a goofball. You can watch it yourself.
Okay.
The the revelation from that debate has already been discussed
multiple times. There's nothing else. But by the way, Krontos
is funny content. His arguments with food shops are not going
to be funny. No, I actually I think Kronto is a good is good
content. That's not what I'm saying. I just I'm not watching
it right now. Not interested, man. >> Do that. >> I
might give this two seconds here. What is this about? >> Well,
yeah, of course, because I think I do it in a good way, but Resir
does not. So, obviously, I find this opening. >> So, here's
the thing, right?
You're not doing it in a safe
uh good environment,
>> But what I'm hearing from you in this call is that you
don't care that you're going to belligerently continue to engage
with the subject matter out of some kind of ridiculous
like, is this vengeance? Like, I don't [__] get it.
Wrong. Okay. >> Did he just mute? Resi, what did Resi intentionally
mute or
Why did this just get muted? The [__] It has to be
muted on his end, right? >> No, not
Why would he have muted right there?
Why did he mute? Oh, maybe he's got music playing or something.
The Twitchbod was muted here. >> Yeah, of course I understand
stigma. >> No. Do you understand stigma? >> Actually,
what does that mean? I said I understand stigma. You asked me
a question, so I said yes. [laughter] Yeah. I want you to quantify
in some way that you understand.
Qualify it. I don't give a [__] >> Choose one.
>> Can you demonstrate stigma to me?
>> The [__] is THAT SUPPOSED TO MEAN? I BRO,
[laughter] IF I ASKED YOU, OKAY, CAN YOU >> YOU CAN'T demonstrate
your understanding, and I appreciate that, which is part of my
issue. So given that you don't understand even just your own
personal experience of being
it's not terminally >> unlike quantify stigma. Nobody knows.
>> I'm talking to you as a as someone who does research
in a
link in the what I say and do impacts for for my field for my
subd discipline. It impacts >> don't you do terrorist research?
>> Yes. And it what I say and do if I am careless
impacts not only just like Muslim people but brown people. It
impacts policy decisions. It impacts more than just you, right?
>> Why the hell does this >> this person in Res's
chat just keeps spamming for I'm assuming Amos Xi is like actually
banned from his chat or something. So they seem to be spamming
Amosqi.
Amos Chi find Jesus >> standard only applies >> because
people hear a [__] belligerent
when you're talking
and they say, "Oh my god, >> what the [__]
is going on?" And then they take
>> That is true. Yes. When people hear food shops speak,
they hear a belligerent. That is absolutely accurate. YES.
IF THEY DON'T BELIEVE IT, they can just ignore it. Who cares?
Okay. All right. They don't have to watch my content. >> They
don't though. That's the diff.
I have the stream where food shops talks about POCD if you want
it. I think I've got that stream as well. You can link it if
you want. You talk about the diagram stream. I think I've gone
over that before as well. >> Right. And so what you say
and do impacts more than just you. You don't want to understand
it from the the personal harm level of
realize every streamer streams without really caring all that
much about the outside audience all that much. Right. >> Fine.
Look at Logic. Look at Chuck. else. I'm talking about you, >> do
you think? Okay, but I'm saying that you don't come at me with
the same energy like you do with other people at all. All right.
I don't see that happening. You You're only doing this because
it's specifically about kids. I get it.